i was just scrolling on linkedin i just
remember seeing this guy in full
military uniform with a rocket launcher
even at the big rock and roll devil
horns and it said congratulate me on the
new job junior rpg operator just not
something you expect to see on linkedin
every day i just thought i'd get in
contact with this guy but i just pinged
him a message hey how's it going
david here from forbes you know which is
a crazy way to communicate with someone
on a battlefield you know we just took
it from there and we got on quite well
mikala is 23 he studied at the kiev
national university of trade and
economics and he's got a bachelor in
management and he's got a master's in
psychology he worked from the i.t side
of developing apps developing websites
mostly for startups his first chat to me
was all about you know helping his
fiancee and cat and dog across to the
west of ukraine where they'd be safe and
then he says he felt it's very powerful
urge to get back to kiev
i am here with my two best friends i am
a project manager and my friends are
iteraculum team leaders when it started
we just made google meeting and said to
each other okay guys we will go to we
will join the army
i asked him what would you guys be doing
otherwise and he sent me this video of
them playing this dancing video game in
front of the screen the next picture i
saw of them they were all forest area
with their rifles and camouflage and
it's just such a such a change
which is quite remarkable that this
country is being defended by i.t
staffers typically working with startups
this generation has has taken the world
of social media and the language that
you use and almost like the meme culture
into battle and i asked him how he came
to be a um a rocket launcher operating
he just told me um
you know there's his commanding officer
just just walked by him one day and said
hey do you do you want to take this on
i said
yeah of course
they
gave me rpg and i said oh great train me
to how to how to deal with it i have to
say that rpg is
very
simple simple uh weapon
i trained about two three days i think
it's quite dangerous because rpg
operators javelin operators snipers it's
target number one i'm not afraid as you
can
see i am have a good mood now because
i'm
confident in our win
he was telling me that he gets off his
patrol they're all chatting talking
camaraderie but they want to know what
people in the u.s people in the uk are
saying and that's unique to this war
really for many years i think ukraine
has been
really well thought of in terms of its
its i.t industry
ukraine has this amazing culture for
maths and programming and coding and all
these things in terms of the talent
there it's very very rich
so mike zapperton over at forbes ukraine
is
an absolute expert on the type of
business and innovation that comes over
from ukraine he cites the likes of
paypal
and whatsapp you know absolute a-list
tech companies these days that have
benefited from having ukrainian talent
as part of their story at a key chapter
of their development he also cites
billionaires like vlad over at revolu
and no conversation about innovation in
ukraine is complete these days without
grammarly
during the first stage of the invasion
of ukraine it became very important for
tech giants billionaire-led businesses
to walk away from russia to turn their
back on russia to remove their services
to remove their presence and to stand in
solidarity with ukraine as it was
attacked these companies should now be
asking themselves how do we help ukraine
build back better people like nicola are
examples of the type of talent that just
gets lost during a war there's plenty of
people who have sacrificed their careers
to join the army people at the beginning
of their careers they get lost for years
it takes these countries to rebuild
elon musk and spacex offer a great
example of how
entrepreneurs and world famous
businesses can help ukraine recover and
rebuild
after this awful war
after the war i will continue my
professional way i hope it will be fast
and i will restore work on my
projects that i had before the work my
clients from the usa
waiting for me
[Music]
you